حسنًا ،
لقد وصف الكرملين غزو
أوكرانيا لأكثر من 300 يوم بأنه عملية عسكرية خاصة ،
أي شخص يصفها بالسجان يواجه روسيا عقوبة
السجن ، ويوجد المئات في السجن لأنهم
فعلوا ذلك تمامًا ، كذلك كان هذا مجرد
زلة لسان من قبل بوتين أو  هل كان هناك المزيد
من الأشياء
التي تعرفها حقًا يمكنني أن أخبرك
بالصدمة عندما رأيت ذلك لأنني أعني أن
الناس في السجن بسبب استخدام
هذه الكلمة بالذات وأنت تعرف
حقًا شيئًا لا يمكن أن
يحدث أبدًا ثم فجأة
يستخدم الرئيس بوتين الكلمة التي أعتقد أنها
مرتين أه في الأماكن العامة ، فماذا يعني ذلك
أعني حسنًا أنه قد يكون هالة من الهراوة
أو قد تكون فكرة أخرى أن
الخطاب الصادر من الكرملين
قد تغير قليلاً والآن
يتحدثون  عن
أمك تعرف نوعًا ما نهاية أه
عملية لتهدئة أوكرانيا والآن هي
حقًا حرب وجودية ضد
العالم وضد يجب أن أقول ضد
الناتو والغرب ولذا أعتقد أنه
عندما تصل إلى هذه النقطة ستشعر بالضيق  من
غير البديهي أن نقول حسنًا
إنها لا تزال عملية عسكرية خاصة ،
لكن من يدري أعني أنه سيتعين علينا أن نسأل
الرئيس بوتين ، أليس كذلك؟
قلنا أنه من الصعب الوصول إلى هذه الأيام على
ما يبدو نعم ، لقد استخدم كلمة الحرب
أممم في سياق واحد من الرغبة في
إنهاء الحرب في أوكرانيا ، إليك كرة صغيرة
من الرئيس الروسي ،
هذه القيادة الأوكرانية منعت
نفسها من التفاوض عاجلاً أم آجلاً ،
بالطبع ، ستجلس أي أطراف في حالة
صراع وتتفاوض في
أقرب وقت على هذا الإدراك.  يأتي إلى أولئك
الذين يعارضوننا ، فمن الأفضل ألا نتخلى عنها أبدًا
لسجل الأوكرانيين الذين
قطعوا المحادثات بسبب جرائم الحرب الروسية المستمرة
داخل أوكرانيا ،
لكن هل هذا غصن زيتون من
بوتين أم جزء من مخطط روسي أنت تعرفه.
أن زيلينسكي حذر بالفعل
من المكان الذي يحاول فيه الروس خلق
هذا الانطباع بأنهم يريدون السلام ، فإن
الأوكرانيين اللعينين هم الذين يريدون إبقائهم
في الحرب ،
ولا أعتقد أن هذا
حقًا  لا شيء جديد يقوله الروس
منذ فترة طويلة ولكن
لا يوجد عمل حقيقي في هذا ،
وإحدى الأفكار على الأقل على الجانب الغربي
هي أن روسيا تريد نوعًا من
تجميد الصراع أه أه يجعل من
الصعب على أوكرانيا الانتقال إلى  افعل
أي شيء لمواصلة هذه العملية
للضغط على والش ثم
آمل أن تنتهي بطريقة ما
ولكن لا أعتقد أن هذا
جديد جدًا حقًا